[Music]
in gone too soon news submitted by Tony
Howe youtuber Desmond etiqa Amitha a
mofo was found was found of apparent
suicide yeah Desmond he was a gamer and
his last maybe about a year already he
has been experiencing or like showcasing
a lot of suicidal thoughts he has been
pretty much trying to he uploaded porn
at one point to his channel to get his
channel take him down
so a lot of self-sabotage a lot of
self-sabotage so he even like
photoshopped himself with a gun and
posted it to Twitter and that prompted
people to call the cops to make sure to
check up on his well-being and there was
this like standoff with cops at one
point and he was live-streaming it she
was taken to the hospital so a lot of
things have been happening in this guy's
life recently he's 29 but or he was 29
by the way and and so recently it's been
reported that he was found in the river
in New York and they have concluded that
it was drowning by suicide so oh damn
suicide by drowning he's also had a lot
of I mean those are all signs of cries
for help that didn't know how to reach
out the right way damn dude that sucks
so he posted an eight minutes goodbye
video and in that video he was
apologizing to everyone in his life
saying you know I'm sorry I pushed you
so far away and I didn't realize I
needed help I didn't realize I was
suicidal but he was pretty much saying
goodbye really crazy about the videos
that in the video it seemed like he was
there was literally nobody around him
like in the city it was just him yeah it
seemed weird you know I mean it was just
like I wish somebody would have just
like bumped into him or something like
just a break that that mental state that
he'd had like a fan like hey dude
picture like something specially helps
me bring back to reality just a small
little oh yeah like if I was just like
it just was
to me and I got sad and I'm outside
walking down the street and someone's
like I'll show you Joe I'm like [ __ ] you
but you want a picture I appreciate that
let's do it and I snatched me out of the
crazy mind people walk these guys were
like we in her or like we just got into
a fight or we're in the middle of a
fight like outside outside of like
Charlie's tree or not how much not
seeing finishing afraid off and then
they were like in the middle of a fight
and there's you can clearly tell because
you got fingers pointing or whatever
excuse me I don't mean to bother you but
we can't get a picture in that pisses me
off I still take the picture yeah but
why are you in the picture like yes so
like there's context clues I know like
well we can't you see me walking man
like yo yeah yeah we're in Japan and I
just found out that Brown guy Joe's dog
yeah and I was like bawling my eyes out
cuz I really loved that dog too and so
we were at some store and then the fan
comes up to us and they're like could we
get a picture I think David was the one
that was like a man right now's not a
good time like they're crying yeah Wow
yeah so I mean sometimes it can be
helpful like in this case hopefully that
would have been helpful but it didn't
happen
we don't know what editors stance on
pictures was - he could have been giving
this video and then some was like hang a
picture he's like I'm gonna take
pictures her we don't know no that's
true everyone has different reactions no
no in his video he was also mentioning
how he hopes that his story will change
YouTube and like social media because he
doesn't get really specific on it but it
seems as though his life on social media
really took him to this point I wish I
knew the specifics cuz we've already
seen so many people come out on social
media like even like Jesse and his girl
prank vs. prank where they came out into
like hey we've been living alive for
years I feel depressed she feels
depressed we've actually been broken up
for the past three years we still make
these videos for you guys and I think
there's this certain level of facade
because the channel is built a certain
way and it has its branding but the
relationship or whatever type of
lifestyle that you have is built into
the branding so you're scared of
during that so there's this kind of like
mental jail that you're in and then
you're pushed to its limits and then
finally when you don't know what to do
like you just have to let everything out
and I think for him I don't know what
his specifics are but he couldn't just
like I guess stop YouTube like he felt
like he had to take his own life it's
crazy when you get to that with truth
when you get to that point you're in
such a tailspin where you can't even see
outside of your own [ __ ] you know I'm
saying so you're like it's over it's
over I [ __ ] it up to the point where I
can't reach out to anyone because
everyone hates me so much and I deserve
this pain yeah cuz then the voice in
your head is going already telling you
you suck you're worthless nobody loves
you and then you go online and then
they're telling you the exact same thing
which validates what you've been telling
yourself so like you said you're just
like you're already in a [ __ ] dark
place and it's that dark place just kind
of closes up on you and you're like look
how do I even begin to get out of this
hole yeah you ever went uh Charlotte
buff had his like he had a breakdown and
he was like on the red carpet with like
a bag on his head saying like I'm not
famous anymore or I'm not a celebrity
anymore so he had a whole breakdown
because of a short form he did which
he's he's way better done I'm a fan of
him so I don't want to like put this
back on like remind people but it's just
I'm glad that he like got through it
because he ended up you know he was he
made an art piece of himself like he's
sat in a room and you can like walk into
the museum and he sit in there and you
can say whatever you want to him like
for like five minutes you didn't like
lash out on him you could do whatever
you want and that was like his self you
know no he was like paying his his dues
or was right exactly the exact price for
what he did for copy or uh he was he
plagiarized somebody's movie book into
his movie yeah it was like a short
frozen Sundance Film Festival and like
he just ripped some guys graphic novel
and basically in his defense it was like
he was trying to creatively do a art
piece and convey his theme but I think
he pulled I written by sorry oh sure
yeah he basically took credit for all of
it and yeah he lifted some guys thing
but then yeah
tailspin and he did a bunch of I thought
pretty funny [ __ ] like where he's like
doing the sitting in a museum and like
having people say whatever they want to
him and then he sit there and cry and
stuff it was really interesting and then
he did this thing to where he would he
watched all of his movies in 24 hours or
something I mean he invited everyone to
come like he I like I like his whole
angle with that's right that's what I'm
saying because I feel like there was
still a way of him being back grounded
and like coping with it
yeah and like and actually like he got
out of the Hollywood scene and like
stars just he went to like a regular
dojo and was just like training and just
like with people in the gym that didn't
recognize him so he felt more human you
know me so I feel I feel like with
social media there should be a balance
of like whether it's your family or your
very best friend from school or
something somebody and it's not
connected with social media like that
maybe they have a Facebook but they're
not really into that world so that you
can remind yourself you know I mean like
get out of that world I know someone
very close to me who went through this
where they were suicidal and they were
gonna go do it oh there are very heavy
in social media yeah and then the family
member called them randomly just out of
the blue and it saved their life it was
like she was driving to a bridge have
any of you guys been felt like you've
been trapped by your own social media I
think so some yeah to a certain extent I
feel it because like you know especially
with the branding that Casey and I have
on our channel it's always really like
positive and family friendly and we
didn't do that intentionally it just
kind of went there and then like you
know we obviously like any other normal
couple a normal family we go through our
own set of problems too but then it just
gets hard to like to be open and real
about it when what and especially in the
middle of it like in the middle of the
filth like it's hard to be like hey you
know by the way we're going through this
[ __ ] right now like you know did you
guys ever want to vlog your fights and
get really cool b-roll that might be big
views energy
no people love drama if you get bu all
of you throwing a bass or something
I don't throw things okay Pacey like
punching a wall you get really good beer
on the really fight anybody dude you
gotta be like hold on honey can you do
that again because we didn't record it
do that's even more toxic like that's
right I guess like for the ugly part of
it for me personally it's healthier for
me to deal with it aside from the
spotlight like you know like I don't
need to put my [ __ ] out on the spotlight
when I'm in the [ __ ] you know I can talk
about it later like once I'm out of it
but do you think it would have been more
healthy if you're able to express it
immediately instead of holding it and
bottling it in I think that's like I
have you guys in my life
like you guys were definitely the ones
that I turn to when things were really
rough oh yeah that was my outlet like
you know if it's if someone all they
have is social media and like it's not
real social support there's no social
support its fakes that's why for me like
I wouldn't have turned to that
immediately as like a healing process
yeah but yeah it's also it's really hard
to still keep up the I don't want to say
like the front like I don't know like
you know you got to do 19 videos on
Japan I mean it's like caviar game day
35 people see through it though like our
recent travel what like if you guys
watch our recent travel try to plug your
own channel check it out if in case you
can try to see if you can see through it
guys like it's a bunch of [ __ ] see
if you can see those little moments to
watch the whole thing but no for real
like for real for real like maybe
because I lived through it I can easily
see but even Casey tells me that when
he's editing the vlogs like it's really
hard for him to hide the [ __ ] because we
were just in such a bad place then and
you know it's just it's hard to like
keep up the pressure I feel like I'm
living a lie too girl yes because jess
is much more mean on camera than she is
in person cuz she's hurt she's actually
not me I know Jess she's kind of the
same
she's not and in that shit's foot that's
just playing huh
she's just hurt and she can't hide it
and so that's why I like because cuz I
relate to her a lot so you know I was
really hurt as well and it just it's
hard to be happy especially when there's
a camera and like your significant other
that hurt you is being like everything's
cool when you're like what the bug yeah
it's not cool yeah like I wish we could
both vet and just like empathize
together instead of one person Bob
having these feelings that one person
that seeming like they're okay exactly
yeah when I talk [ __ ] about her I'm
heightening it I'm not even being honest
to kind of flip it a bit um I do kind of
see the perks of social media as well
cuz then there's times where you know
I've seen people being in a bad place or
even myself if I'm just having a bad day
it just takes that really cool comment
of a fan going dude you know what like
this is ty I respect what you do I look
up to
this is motivating and then it it'll
snap me out of whatever mood I'm in I'm
like yeah what the [ __ ] am i trippin on
like yeah like that's kind of tight like
this person like has my back if she
watch our vlogs and see the happiness I
like that I like the idea that somebody
out there is like you know what I really
want to make Gio's day-to-day and they
go on their computer and then they're
like hey I just wanted to say like you
have really cool boobs but no people
don't see that they always start off
like this and I think it's [ __ ] cute
but every single DM that I've gotten
it's always like I know you're not gonna
read this but and then it's like a it
follows a really cool message I'm like
oh you should respond back quit being
such a low self-esteem loser they read
them guys
yeah and then Jill you're totally right
because as soon as all come across a
comment or DM that's like so uplifting
I'm like thank you so much thank you
think I didn't read it I'm gonna flip
though like that in a relationship that
could be so annoying
when y'all just getting the argument and
then your girl would like go like in the
bathroom to take a shower selfie t like
feeling good I think I get a little
smile like about to get [ __ ] line
yeah but to give it better you just like
you just go that's how you feel that's
how you feel like you know me just go
get cantaloupe or wax on yourself it is
a turn to like a happiness war like
right right when you're done with the
argument and then it's just like item
I'm about to go on set right now and
like you know set life or you know me
and happy yeah and then the [ __ ] the
followers are just like damn this couple
is lit right now I would it be like
they're like so happy
dude nikki ever left me I would be at
Disney World every single day that's a
season pass or whatever I know I would
love it now then we'll piss her off even
more that you know she's like oh he
hates his [ __ ] suits ever drinking water
every day I find out that Monster Energy
Cheetos a bunch of carcinogens swish we
just clicked
for some reason today I had an epiphany
and all of it
I bet Diet Coke is so terrible for you I
think you came up with the ideas exactly
I think here's what I don't need any
more somebody put an apple on a bathtub
filled it with diet coke look what
happened to the poor Apple I started
posting the last [ __ ] see they can get
it can give like you know crazy you know
I mean
[Music]